[Captioned via Y Translator]
Guys, we've been working
on something big,
and we are excited to unveil it
in just a couple of weeks
once everything is ready.
In the meantime,
we want to hear your guesses
about what it is.
The first person who guesses it
correctly will get it for free.
Post your guesses down in the comments,
and start using the #TKORCreator
so your guesses are
seen on social media.
Also, if you click the link
in the description below,
you can sign up for our mailing list
so you can get updates
about what's to come.
[Music]
Hey guys, today, we are here
with my friend Joseph,
and we're going to do something
that a lot of you have asked about.
We are going to do
some introductory blacksmithing.
Now Joseph, tell us about what
blacksmithing experience you have.
Well, I first got into it when
I was 11 by reading books.
I found a reference in a book
to an old way the blacksmith's
practice, which is to forge clay,
which does not require the hot fire
or any of the dangerous stuff.
And so it's a really good way
to start in your kitchen.
We'll take some refrigerated
oil-based clay,
and learn some basic
blacksmithing techniques.
Once we've got those techniques down,
we'll use our backyard foundry
as a furnace,
and apply what we've learned
to some real iron.
All right, so we are going to show
you a little bit of blacksmithing
with real metal and real fire.
But then we're also going to show you
Joseph's practicing method where you
use oil-based clay that
you have refrigerated
and the tools are the same.
Yup, tools are exactly the same,
and the techniques are exactly the same.
Cool thing about Clay is
actually a really good analog
for the way hot metal behaves,
and so you can learn how to forge
tapers and to do upsetting,
to punch and do all the stuff,
and it's actually less
forgiving than iron,
and so it's a really good way to practice
and see where you're making mistakes.
Brilliant.
So, all right,
talk about the tools.
Okay, so hammers have a couple
of different faces.
Typically you'll have a face
of the hammer which is flat,
and then you have a back-end
which does something else.
This will flatten metal in all directions,
and so, as you squish the metal,
it's going to squish this way,
and this way.
The most common type
of blacksmithing hammer
is called a cross peen hammer,
and this thing is insanely useful,
because this back end,
when you hit metal with it, is only
going to spread metal in this axis,
and a lot less in this axis,
which is really good
for stretching out metal
in areas where you want it.
You also have straight peens,
which have the same kind
of chisel shape just done vertically.
This is a crossbeam.
I found one.
Yeah.
This one is a ball-peen.
You've probably seen this type before,
and this one is useful for dishing
and making spoons, and it's more
of an aggressive spread of metal
at one kind of point.
And this is an anvil.
What is this made of?
This is a Harbor
Freight junk Anvil.
Do you know is
this iron or steel
or?
This is cast iron.
How much does
this anvil weight?
This anvil 55 pounds.
I'm so strong.
55 pounds.
Oh wow.
So we have our 55-pound cast iron anvil,
a variety of hammers.
Maybe let's try a little bit
of room temperature clay,
and then we'll move
to the refrigerated clay,
which is more like the actual metal.
And then we'll eventually
move up to the actual metal.
Oil-based clay, and so,
this is just the stuff that you can get
at like a craft store, right?
Yes.
This is the stuff that
kids can play with.
Bright colored stuff.
And this is, when
you would say oil-based,
you mean that this is a thick
probably about the consistency
of petroleum jelly type
of oil with a substrate in it,
and this doesn't dry out
because this has no water
in it to dry out.
You could leave this out for a year,
and it would get dusty,
but it would still
be pretty much the same.
Step one.
Take a hammer,
try squishing it just
to get a sense for how that goes.
You want the most power you
can get with perfect control.
So here I have tons of control,
but not much power.
Here, I've got loads of power
but like my aim is going to be way off.
Yeah, because this is
room temperature clay,
we need like no -- no power.
So err on the side of control.
You're seeing the divots that
your hammer is making?
Yes.
You want to be aware of those.
Any tilting of your hammer
like this or like this
or like this is going to make dents.
So when I-- When I keep
the hammer relatively flat here,
I get only very very
minor denting along the edges.
But if-- but if I angle my hand wrong
and then hit in the middle, I suddenly have
this big old crescent-shaped,
and I assume in metal,
that's kind of hard to get out.
Yes, very much!
Clay is slightly,
it's less forgiving than metal.
But you're going to get
the same effect with metal,
and so this is a good way to make sure--
I can see them.
I'm flattening down on top of it,
and like it's still visible that crease
I put in there earlier.
Lift up the clay
from the anvil.
It's going to try to stick to the anvil,
so you're going to want to lift it
every couple of hits.
Just to make sure it doesn't stick.
So regularly.
Yes.
Remove it from the anvil.
That does not happen
with real metal.
Okay.
Now try slipping at 90 degrees,
and stretching this out.
Yeah, you'll notice that now
that this is kind of spatula shape
because you were spreading
the clay in this direction.
In this direction,
this direction,
not so much into the bar though.
Exactly.
And so now try
getting this the same--
I'm gonna rotate it,
and we're going to try
and make equal thickness to this again?
Yes.
>> All right.
And now you'll notice
it's puckering.
So flip it again 90 degrees,
and fix the pucker.
Now, I've got like
this chisel shape.
Yeah.
So do I want to flip it back
to the first spot side
or on to the other side?
If you flip it on the other side,
you'd want to bring it to the edge
of the anvil right here,
so that you can maintain
that place where it changes thickness.
[Music]
Yeah.
All right.
I've still got kind
of this channel going down
the middle, is that...
Yeah, that's pretty
normal for starting.
See if you could smooth
it out as best you can.
With refrigerated clay
or with hot metal,
I would have to be hitting this a lot harder.
Yes, but you also
need less of this.
You get a trade-off,
and that it's harder
to make big mistakes when it's harder.
This is similar to working
at a low red heat when
you're blacksmithing.
Typically, what smiths will do is
they will forge the rough shape,
and then at a cooler temperature,
they will take out the dents.
Interesting.
I have a slightly
flatter piece of clay.
It took me several minutes with
a hammer and an anvil to do it.
The next thing I'd like
to show you how to do is
how to make a leaf.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to use this hammer
for most of what I'm doing.
All right.
And the first thing I'm going to do
is what's called drawing a taper,
which means I want to make this pointy.
So I'm going to take my hammer
and angle it, and I'm
going to angle my clay a little bit,
and I'm going to whack it,
rotating 90 degrees every time.
So now it's pointy,
and the next thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to hold it
over the edge of the anvil,
and I'm going to whack right
over the transition between the Anvil
and empty space,
and that's going to create that shape,
that kind of step down.
You see that?
Yes.
Now I'm going to do the same thing
on the other side.
I'm going to rotate that.
This is forming the transition
from the leaf and the stem.
So now I've got
the stem thinner.
Now, I'm going to round off the
corners by pointing the corner up
to make it into an octagon.
And now just getting it as smooth
and round as I can.
So now it's round.
But I'm going to set this
on the anvil like this.
I'm going to make it flat,
and I could finish it there,
but I'm not going to,
and so what I'm going to do
is unstick it.
Now, I'm going to use the cross peen end
of the hammer to rotate out the shape
of the leaf, and also
put in the definition.
And there, you've got a leaf.
And then the last thing you want to do,
I'm going to throw a hammer out here to
simulate having an actual step down here.
I'm going to hold it
over this spot right here.
I'm going to tap it to give
it a little bit of character,
and then, I'm going to tap down the tip
to make it look a little more organic.
And there's the leaf.
Brilliant.
All right.
How long do you have to practice
before your forearm
starts having strength,
and not getting really sore very quickly?
It depends on how much
rock climbing you do.
Hmm, not enough apparently.
[Music]
I leafed.
You leafed.
Frozen clay compared
to regular clay.
My forearm is already sore
from holding a hammer.
So this is going
to get interesting.
So same process?
Same process.
Oh my gosh, that's harder.
[Music]
That's a great point.
Thank you.
Do a step down.
There we go.
So I've got a bowl of ice
and water and salt.
Make this our sort
of reverse forge.
Let the clay sit in there
for a few seconds.
If you're doing something
with this out of metal,
how long would you be throwing back
in the forge for--
It depends on how thick it is.
So the super thin areas like this spot
are going to change temperature faster,
so they don't have to go in
the forge for very long.
If you're doing something
really thick, you can wait
until you're an old man.
Like just forever.
Is that enough
or should I go thin?
That's perfect.
So now you have some room
to work with?
[Music]
Now, we move onto metal.
Yes.
Metal.
It was the...
Like what are we looking for?
How do we know when it's ready?
The nice thing about iron is
that it changes colors to tell you what,
how hot it is.
So the scale of blacksmithing color starts
at what they call a cherry red,
or a low red,
and then you work your way up
through reddish orange to orange,
to reddish yellow to yellow to...
At that point, the metal
actually catches on fire.
And so what color are we
looking for an orange?
This is a mild steel bar that
we've got right here.
And so this is workable all
the way down to a really low red.
And so anything where
it's glowing, we can hit it.
So about here.
This is this is how far I can grab this
before it starts getting
uncomfortably warm.
It is warm.
I mean, this part's warm.
Back here, like there's
quite a heat difference
between right there and right there.
So I feel pretty safe holding right here,
and you do notice I have bare hands,
that helps me feel how
the steel is doing what--
Once I feel it cooling off
too much under my hand,
then I'll know it might be
time to throw it back in.
All right, let's see
about flattening this a little bit.
[Music]
Got some fun flaking here.
Yeah.
This is a magnetite.
What's happened is some
of the metal has returned
to its ore state.
This is the black sand that the Japanese
smiths used to make their swords,
except they find it naturally occurring.
[Music]
What do you think Joseph?
The finest leaf that
blacksmithing has ever seen?
Probably the best one ever
that no one has ever made a better Leaf.
I like the definition that
you manage to put in here.
That's actually, considering
how tired you were from all
the stuff we've been doing before,
that's not bad for hammer control,
and then you managed to get all
the individual steps right
all the way up to here.
So that's awesome.
And there's very very
little carps from map here.
So good taper, good set down,
good texturing.
Well done.
Intro to blacksmithing is
actually pretty simple.
We've shown you a couple of different ways
of how to make forges that you could use
for this technique.
Our classic stand up
in a bucket forge,
and then our smaller paint can forge,
those are both things that would work
for this process.
You just have to have a little bit
of patience, plenty of fuel,
and a few tools.
Some hammers
and an anvil are...
No matter which forge
you decide to try with,
exercise lots and lots of caution.
Rule number one of blacksmithing,
even if the metal looks black,
it is still hot enough to melt your flesh.
So like assume
everything's hot.
I assume everything
is trying to kill you.
Be careful with the fire
and don't die.
Thank you to Joseph
for teaching me the beginning steps
of blacksmithing using
the freezing cold clay.
That works great as an analog,
and then moving up to steel.
This steel is probably
barely a step above iron,
but I made it.
Guys, thanks for watching.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top
will transport you directly
to our last video.
You should check that out.
The other box at the bottom
will show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you aren't a subscriber yet,
just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way you never
miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.